The Internet is like a breeding ground for conspiracy theories.
While some are just stupid and funny,
others promote ignorance and an unhealthy distrust.
So we went to the codes because out Glam and developed a foolproof system to
destroy.
Not all,
but a lot of conspiracy theories.
It's really simple.
Just ask yourself,
does the theory affects really rich and powerful people?
Is the answer?
Yes.
Okay,
then it's most likely not true.
Let's test it on three examples.
Number one,
there's an easy cure for cancer,
but it's with help because it would destroy the profits of Pharma companies.
Do really rich people die of cancer like my to know,
say the former CEO of apple.
Yes,
there is no suppressed cure for cancer.
Number two,
chem trails.
The theory that airplanes,
it sprayed chemicals in the air for population control or some other crazy
reason don't really powerful.
People breathe air.
Do Obama or Putin breathe air?
Yes.
Chem trails are not a thing.
Number three,
apocalyptic conspiracy theories.
The world will end soon because of the antichrist.
Meyers aliens.
Someone says,
so do really rich and powerful people ignore the soon to be upon us and very
eminent apocalypse.
Yes,
the world will not.
And soon,
this obviously doesn't work for every conspiracy theory out there,
but it does work for some of the most stupid ones.
So the next time someone tries to convince you that the Illuminati but stuff in
your water,
just show them this video and maybe be a bit more selective about your friends
on Facebook.